moi je viens d'entendre au téléphone
vous assure sa voix elle est hyper
sensuel un nom en revanche elle a
forcément get away m'a fait attention
quand même parce qu'une femme
ça m'a vachement plus que nous jules
elle a 40 ans enfin je veux dire c'est
margot qu'on attend pas jeanne moreau va
très bien pour lui des cases en plus de
25 ans elles sont ménopausées
mais non mais non c'est pas ça mais
c'est une femme quand ça vieillit bon
même ça se voit pas trop débuts à part
les ridules au coin des yeux à moi
j'aime bien j'ai dû me prenais cieux du
coup je m'en fous moi aussi j'adore ça
je superjoue pinousse de la d'accord moi
aussi j'aime bien ça je trouve même que
c'est leur donne du charme de problème
c'est pas ça le problème c'est leur peau
mais quoi leur peau est bas les femmes
passé trente ans elles ont la peau molle
sous c'est que ces conneries ils ont la
peau molle alors isabelle à 40 ans aussi
à la pala pour moulins non ça c'est
parce que tu es habitué
tu te rends pas bien compte c'est vrai
que quand j'étais encore avec virginie
je faisais pas trop gaffe mais
maintenant je suis de nouveau sur le
marché alors faudrait mettre un plus ces
jeunes puissent se faire un bilan dix
appels à poux super ferme
d'accord d'accord
d'abord elle fait du sport deux fois par
semaine bon ben alors là oui oui je
dépends des femmes que par faire des
généralités comme ça lacombe
non au potentiel